ce n'est pas une soirée heureuse pour
nous que celle ci pour la seconde fois
en france l'extrême droite gagne
l'élection européenne assise se confirme
que notre pays prend une pente que nous
continuerons à combattre par tous les
moyens dont nous disposons
monsieur macron semble avoir perdu le
match qu'il avait voulu installer de
façon si responsable c'est de fait la
victoire de l'extrême droite
l'effondrement du pouvoir dans le match
qu'il avait engagée et le niveau de
l'abstention qui reste considérablement
élevé montrent que notre pays s'enfonce
dans une crise profonde
nul n'en aperçoit à cette heure l'issue
positive notre responsabilité restera
donc de tâches et de l'ouvrir de
continuer à tracer le chemin que nous
avions d'abord inauguré
si vaillamment dans ce contexte notre
résultat est très décevant il n'est pas
à la hauteur de nos espérances là bas de
soie et encore moins de nos efforts
mais je veux saluer manon aubry et ses
colistières et colistiers qui ont dans
cette bataille jeter toute leur force de
conviction et d'espérance je veux saluer
les milliers de femmes et d'hommes qui
ont pris leur place dans la bataille et
qui ont déployé tous les efforts qu'ils
étaient dans leurs moyens pour
convaincre
convaincre convaincre encore quoi qu'il
en soit ce résultat assure la présence d
un soumis au parlement européen dans ces
conditions conjointement avec le groupe
des parlementaires de l'assemblée
nationale
nous allons continuer la bataille contre
les menaces écologiques qui s'avance et
les injustices sociales qui s'aggrave
nous le ferons comme d'habitude avec
toute notre énergie
avec ce point d'appui essentiel que sont
tous ces jeunes élues femmes et hommes
qui sont entrés dans la lutte à nos
côtés nous sauront assumer nos
responsabilités et j'invite à ce que se
fédère tous ceux qui partagent cette
volonté et qu'ils comprennent à quel
point la lutte engagée dépend de la
force de conviction et d'engagement de
chacun la pente qui est prise est
mauvaise il est possible de l'inversé
mais cela reste impossible si chacun en
conscience ne prend pas pour lui-même
ses responsabilités c'est l'heure des
combats et des caractères
la france en a toujours disposé en
abondance
je forme le voeu qu'elle sache se
manifester se rassembler pour parvenir
aux objectifs qu'elle doit se donner
libérer une bonne foi le pays
le système de notre vie de la pesanteur
économiques entiers écologique qui
pèsent sur lui et des ombres que
projette sur son destin
l'extrême droite vive la république vive
la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]